hal holbrook and designing women star
dixie carter were married
for 25 years until she died of cancer
back in 2010
and now with the news of hal's passing
we can only imagine
that these two are together again
i think it's good to have married hal
holbrook probably
i recommend it for anybody who can get
him
hal told us over the years his greatest
roles in life were father and husband to
the love of his life dixie who he wed
in 1984. well my greatest interest
aside from fooling around with dixie
are uh we flew around with our children
a lot
the 95 year old screen and stage legend
passed away at his home january 23rd
e.t was on set of designing women with
the couple in 1988
hal played dixie's on-screen boyfriend
for four seasons
i trust all of you have heard the news
about recent nuptials
in 2008 at 82 years old he made history
as the oldest man to receive an acting
oscar nomination for his role in
into the wild i'm gonna miss you when
you go
and there was no bigger cheerleader than
dixie
pure unadulterated gorgeous it was like
mozart
[Music]